surveiller un site identifié un intrus
grâce à une caméra thermique des actions
parfois invisibles à l'oeil possible
grâce aux drones un appareil radio
commandé comme ceux développés par le
groupe france et gorron montré la
capacité et surtout l'utilité du drone
aujourd'hui on sait qu'un drone
forcément et moins chère à l'utilisation
connelly kopter et ça de nombreuses
directions l'ont compris depuis
longtemps c'est pour ça qu'elles font
appel à nous puisqu'aujourd'hui 1h
d'hélicoptères son prix d'utilisation
varie entre 1000 et 2000 euros alors que
le drone ne lui coûtent moins de 100
euros à l'utilisation alors plusieurs
membres du happy hour business club ont
pu tester ces appareils une conférence
était proposé ce mardi sur le circuit
jean-pierre beltoise
je trouve ça semble d'utilisation parce
que voilà il ya un je tique un joystick
gauche pour aller à droite et à gauche
et injuste droite pour avancer en
arrière c'est facile à prendre mais je
pense que c'est une utilisation qui se
substitue pas à l'être humain mais qui
vient en complément et en aide surtout
par exemple dans le domaine de recherche
de personnes qui est un secteur qui
m'intéresse et que pour lequel je fais
moi-même cette activité à titre de
loisir avec avec un chien en france
toute personne souhaitant piloter un
drone de plus de 800 grammes doit passer
un certificat deux pilotes de loisirs